[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm delighted to welcome you and to
welcome dr. John Hume our guest for the
third Ford MIT Nobel laureate lecture
the Nobel Prize recognizes contributions
of uncommon excellence and impact in a
variety of fields dr. Humes Peace Prize
in 1998 is in that great tradition I'm
also delighted to acknowledge the Ford
Motor Company for its support of this
lecture series that aims to bring the
very best thinking on great issues to
the MIT community we're also grateful
for the cooperation of the MIT lecture
series committee the graduate student
council and the undergraduate
Association a couple of housekeeping
matters after the lecture dr. Hume will
rech will accept questions from the
audience and following the program we
invite the audience to a reception in
the lobby of the Student Center
finally a future note on Tuesday
February 19th 2002 the fourth Nobel
laureate lecture will be given by dr.
david baltimore president of the
california institute of technology and
winner of the nobel prize and biology in
1998 the Nobel Committee recognized dr.
John Hume and David tremble for their
contributions to peace in Northern
Ireland for more than 30 years violence
and unrest based on religious political
and social unrest and bias in Northern
Ireland cost more than 3500 lives and
caused untold horrors and pain the
presence of violence stunted economic
growth that fed even more violence
throughout this period
John whom was the most articulate voice
in Northern Ireland's political
leadership in the struggle to achieve a
just peace
dr. Hume started on the path toward
peace as a leader of the nonviolent
civil rights movement in the late 1960s
he went on to establish a record of
community leadership he served as a
special adviser to the European
Community Commissioner and various other
groups dr. Hume is presently a member of
the British and European Parliament's
dr. Hume played two important other
critical roles he helped to create
institutions in Europe and in Ireland
that respected diversity such as the
Council of Ministers the European
Commission and the European Parliament
drawing on the European strength the
Solidarity with American and European
Peace collaborators he was able to bring
out the best among all parties to create
a lasting peace
dr. Hume also recognized the powerful
connection between economic development
and peace and is now a champion for the
nation-building that will ultimately
keep conflict under control it is
fitting in this current conflict and
outrage over the tragedy of September
11th that we have an opportunity to have
a true soldier of peace share his views
on the subject the philosophy of
conflict resolution it is my distinct
honor and high privilege to introduce to
you Nobel laureate John Hume
thank you
thank you very much I'm very pleased to
be with you this evening lift up your
faces you have a piercing need for this
bright morning dawning for you history
despite its wrenching pain cannot be
unlived and if faced with courage need
not be lived again these are the words
of the poet Maya Angelou they are words
of hope there are words that should
inspire us all at this time of great
challenge that we must never give up the
search for a better world in the search
for an end to war and suffering and in
the search for peace and justice we
shouldn't give up because we're living
in a very historic time in the history
of the world we're leaving
one of the worst centuries in the
history of the world two world wars
millions of people slaughtered and of
course we're living also through the
biggest revolution in the history of the
world
the technological telecommunications and
transport revolution the world is a much
smaller place in your generation than it
has ever been so as we enter in the new
century in the smaller world and leave
behind it century of two world wars let
us have our dream and work for the dream
that war and conflict has been left
behind and that we will be building a
new world in which there will be total
respect for our common humanity and
recognize that our common humanity
transcends our difference it's a great
personal honor for me to be here this
evening at the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology to deliver the four Nobel
lecture on the theme of the philosophy
of conflict resolution the people of
Boston and the people of Massachusetts
and indeed wider America have been true
and very consistent friends of my
country of Ireland and of our peace
process our shared history and ancestry
along with the very vibrant connections
that exists today provides us all with
the inspiration we need to ensure that
we will all enjoy our future the limits
which are set only at the limits of our
own creativity and our own imagination
it's a great city of Boston has been a
true friend of my own home town of Derry
through the troubles over the years we
have made many friends and I have made
many friends in that city whose support
and friendship has been pivotal as I
worked for economic regeneration and job
creation has a very central role of our
peace process because central to my own
philosophy my own political philosophy
has always been the belief that by
making real politics work and by real
politics I don't mean waving flags at
one another I mean addressing the real
issues of people and living standards of
employment of education of housing of
healthcare that we can change the
dynamic of our society by concentrating
in those and transform that society all
too many young people from my own City
of Derry and of course the north of
Ireland got caught up in parliamentarism
as a consequence of the crushing
unemployment rates that crippled our
prospects for peace and prosperity
because they had no hope and
discrimination was at the heart of it in
an effort to address that particular
problem I was involved in creating a
project that became known as Derry
Boston ventures its purpose was to
promote economic development between the
two cities that share
so much history and with the help of
many of our friends in Boston that
became a huge success leading to the
creation of many new jobs providing many
of our young people with hope and
prosperity as I say real politics indeed
I believe it's highly appropriate at the
venue for this speech is here because
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
is renowned as one of the leading lights
on the world stage in education and
technology particularly in this modern
smaller world that I'm talking about and
given my commitment again to developing
the IT sector in my home city I keep
telling my people that my vision is at
the Foyle Valley which is our Valley
should become the Silicon Valley of
Europe allowing the vast potential of
information and communications
technology to be fully maximized our
city Derry has a youthful energetic and
very well educated population and our
University at Magee College was one of
the best IT centres of any college in
Ireland we have a human resource base
there that a second to none and I'm
determined that its full potential be
fulfilled as part of our peace process
by working closely with you people and
in the intervening years of course we
have developed Derry Boston ventures now
and it's known as the Derry investment
initiative and I'm very glad that so
that one of the leading figures and
chief executive of that body is with me
here this evening the support of those
real friends of Derry here in your part
of the world has been invaluable as we
have worked to provide and to foster new
opportunity for our young people today
we are closer than we've ever been in
Ireland to reversing the historic tide
of emigration that has brought so many
Irish people to these shores over many
years
today more and more of our young people
are thankfully growing up free from
violence and able to live and work in
the country of their birth and today I
want to pay tribute to the people of
America who have stood with us over
those years to get peace and whose help
is so central to building her new
society in that new Ireland because your
country has been a rock solid friend of
our peace process in Northern Ireland
and continues to be the support offered
by United States has been vital as we
work to leave our conflict behind
without the United States the peace
process might never have succeeded and
perhaps we may have never been able to
reach the historic agreement of Good
Friday in 1998 for example our problem
when you analyze it is about three sets
of relationships we disagreed about our
relationships with in Northern Ireland
with in Ireland and between Ireland and
Britain
therefore to solve the problem those
three relationships should be the agenda
at any talks and that being the case the
talk should be conducted not by one
government but by two governments
British and Irish governments and all
the parties of Northern Ireland and
that's common sense and it has happened
but it took a long time to get two
governments to agree to work together
yet in 1977 the first statement ever
made by a president of the United States
about the Irish problem was made by
Jimmy Carter and he was strongly advised
to make the statement by four people
that I'll talk about in a moment but the
statement said called on the British and
Irish governments to work together to
solve the problem of Northern Ireland
and if they did so they would get
economic support from America and that
signs today a very common-sense and
normal statement but in 1977 it was a
very revolutionary statement and it
finally happened in 1998 when the two
governments and the parties could round
the table
for the Good Friday Agreement but Jimmy
Carter was persuaded to say that by four
men that we called that I work closely
with and they were known as the four
horsemen
senator Kennedy and let me say in this
state that there no American has done
more for peace in my country and your
senator when I was elected as a very
young man in 1970 my phone rang this is
Ted Kennedy could I meet you I want to
keep briefed on your problems because
that's when the problems we started we
met in Germany and from there onwards he
kept in regular contact kept himself
totally fully informed and took
necessary issued initiatives and of
course the late speaker Tip O'Neill who
was a great friend of Ireland and Hugh
Carey of New York and Pat Moynihan of
New York and when the two governments
first got together in 1985 and signed
anglish agreement the following day my
phone rang Tip O'Neill John we keep our
promises having promised to economically
support the two governments that they
came together we're setting up the
International Fund for Ireland that fund
has already created 38,000 jobs for our
young people and Northern Ireland and
the border counties Thank You Tip
O'Neill and Ed Kennedy presently of
course I'm given the situation of course
that we're in that bringing together
people and the economy scene is part of
what I call the healing process but as I
was saying at the beginning the
challenge that now faces is to leave the
conflicts of past centuries behind us
and as we enter the new century in the
new millennium that is built it
as a world of peace and as regions of
peace with no conflict because when you
have a look at conflict no matter where
it is and this is me talking very simply
but I think it's also quite profound
all conflict is about the same thing no
matter where it is it's about difference
whether difference is your religion or
your race or your nationality and the
message that we have to get across from
that we have learned in our part of the
world is it difference is an accident of
birth none of us chose to be born and we
certain didn't choose to be born into
any particular community there's not two
people in this Hall who are the same
there's not two people in the whole
world who are the same difference is of
the essence of humanity and therefore
respect for difference should be very
very normal and very common but it is a
first undi pused principle of real peace
and real ending of conflict and look at
our conflict in Northern Ireland over
the past thirty years with a population
of a million and a half three thousand
seven hundred people lost their lives
were killed one out of 450 people that's
the equivalent of half a million people
being killed in the United States in
percentage terms that's how serious it
was and of course in addition to that
over 40,000 people were maimed and
injured that's it that's one out of 50
people that's the equivalent of five
million people in the United States
being maimed or injured that's how
serious our conflict has been and
therefore how difficult it was to bring
it to an end and it was also necessary
because of that in the highest
church-going city in Europe Belfast to
build
walls up to 12 volts to separate and
protect one section of a Christian
people from another I always described
those walls as an indictment of all of
us because as I said our past attitudes
had built them and for that reason we
should regard them as a challenge to us
a challenge to change our past attitudes
and when you look at our past attitudes
or our mentalities you'll find those
mentalities also exist in most areas of
conflict there's a mentality of the
unionist people in Northern Ireland who
are largely the Protestant population
and I called that the Afrikaner mindset
the Afrikaner mentality they wish to
protect their identity and they rightly
wish to protect their identity within
Ireland and I would have no quarrel with
that because it's as I say diversity
enriches Society and therefore it's
right that they should wish to protect
their identity my quarrel with them was
their method of protecting it the
Afrikaner method as I called it holding
all power in their own hands in other
words if you weren't a unionist in
Northern Ireland when we were growing up
you had great difficulty he never would
be in power of any description in
politics but you also would have great
difficulty in getting a job or getting a
heist or even getting a vote voting was
given to only those people who paid
relates and rents and when I would be
growing up if I had been avoiding aids
the only people who would have votes in
the house would be the father and mother
and if you and if you owned a company a
business company each business company
had six boats and when I was young the
mayor of Derry had 43 votes because he
owned seven companies
each of which had six votes plus his own
boat and of course we suffered terrible
discrimination in jobs and housing and
although they were only thirty percent
of the population the unionists ruled
the city by a system of gerrymander that
was the Afrikaner mindset our challenge
to that was discrimination of that
nature will at the end only lead to
conflict and it's not the correct way to
protect your identity and my challenge
to them was because of your geography
and your numbers in Northern Ireland the
problem can't be solved without you
therefore come to the table and reach an
agreement that will protect your
identity forever in other words dialogue
and dialogue is central to a peace
process in any Devine society then of
course there was a mentality of my own
community what's called the nationalist
mentality or the nationalist mindset and
of course I challenge that as well I
call that the territorial mindset
Ireland is our land
your unionists are a minority in our
land and you can't stop as uniting and
of course there's a lot of quarrels in
the world about land and territory but
my talents to that mindset was look hold
on a minute here it's people that have
rights not territory even without people
even Ireland our beautiful island is
only a jungle and when people are
divided as they are in Ireland they can
never be brought together with guns and
bombs the division can only be deepened
by guns and bombs and the problem made
far more difficult to solve and of
course if one side uses guns and bombs
the other replies with guns and bombs
and his Martin Luther King and Mahatma
Gandhi kept repeating and we did as well
the old doctrine of an eye for an eye
leaves everybody
blind violence in other words had no
role to play and solving our problem and
of course given that we are divided
people and not a divided piece of earth
once again the only solution is
agreement and getting together in
dialogue to reach that agreement so the
challenge to both mentalities as I have
made clear in my few words recently to
you was to come to the table and reach
agreement as to how they share the piece
of earth together and of course that
wasn't easy but we eventually succeeded
and I have to admit but in my work as a
political leader in working for that
agreement and getting the violence
stopped on our streets
I was very heavily inspired by my
European experience because I'm a member
of the European Parliament where I have
been since 1979 and when I first went
there and I always tell this story when
I first went to Strasbourg to the
European Parliament meeting in 1979 I
went for a walk and I crossed the bridge
from Strasbourg which is in France to
kale which is in Germany and I stopped
and I thought good lord
if I had stood in this bridge 30 years
ago 1949 just after the Second World War
35 million people slaughtered and if I
had said don't worry it's all over and
in 20 years time we'll have a united
Europe the quarrel will be over and the
French will still be friends and the
Germans will still be German I said to
myself have I thought that 30 years ago
hydron sent a psychiatrist but it
happened
and the European Union when you think of
it today is the best example in the
history of the world of conflict
resolution and for that reason the
principles and philosophy at the heart
of it should be studied by every area of
conflict and brought to every area of
conflict and when you look at the
principles they're simple and
straightforward
the first principle as I've talked about
already was respect for difference
because what was there Wars about and
respect for difference is a fundamental
principle of European Union no victory
for any country second principle
creating institutions which respect with
those differences a Council of Ministers
which meets under the minister from
every country and no matter how small or
large the country is none of them can
dominate the others they work by
agreement and the second institution is
the European Commission which is a civil
service of European Union drawn from all
member countries and the third is the
European Parliament drawn from all
member countries no victories for any
but they're all there and then the third
principle which is the most important
principle of all which is what I call a
healing process they work together in
their common interests which was largely
economics the areas of agreement they
spilt their sweat as I always say and
not their blood and by working together
in their common interests broke down the
barriers of centuries and the new Europe
has evolved and is still evolving and
the Lord only started it with six
countries there's no 15 there those same
principles are at the heart of our
agreement of Good Friday and
Ireland when you look at it principle
number one respect for difference there
was no victory for either community in
our agreement total respect for the
unionist identity total respect for the
nationalist identity second principle
institutions which respected those
differences and assembly elected to
Northern Ireland by a voting system of
proportional representation which
ensures that all sections of the people
are totally democratically represented
and then that assembly proportionally
elects the government or executive and
all sections are represented in the
government and then the third principle
of course which is the most important is
that our representatives from all
sections of our community work together
in our common interests the economic
growth spill our sweat not our blood and
that's the real healing process working
our common grind together and as we do
so as we spill our sweat and not our
blood break down the barriers of
centuries of distrust and Prejudice and
the new Ireland will evolve in a
generation or two based on agreement and
respect for difference Anna Deena come
back to the importance of the United
States in that healing process area
because given that the healing process
is working the common ground together
the economic development wiping out
unemployment and given real hope to our
young people that they can earn a living
in the land of their birth the United
States is a very important role to play
in that and already are playing it
through as I said earlier when our four
horsemen friends set up the
International Fund for Ireland but as in
addition to that American investment and
of course the marketing of the products
of our small industries in the United
and of course in recent times we've been
very fortunate again in my own City in
attracting major American investments my
city is now the European headquarters of
DuPont Fruit of the Loom seagate Stream
international and under their roofs
young people from both communities are
working together and as they work
together our dream and hope is of course
that we will break down the barriers of
the past and the trust will grow and a
new Ireland believer all based on
agreement and respect for difference and
let me say to you now and I'm sure that
many of you have forgotten it the
philosophy that I am talking to you
about tonight there's a philosophy that
find it your country and you will find
it summarized if you pull a cent out of
your pocket and read it because there it
is written and I learned about it by
studying your history as well the three
words and if you can't if your
eyesight's not good enough to read the
cent go to the grave of Abraham Lincoln
and there you will see the message a
pluribus unum from many we are one the
essence of our unity is respect for our
diversity the real philosophy of peace
respect for difference look at the whole
human race as I said earlier humanity
transcends nationality humanity
transcends race and religion etc first
and foremost we're human beings and our
common humanity therefore demands that
we respect our diversity when I was a
ward at the Nobel Peace Prize in 98 I
quoted the Irish poet William Butler
Yeats who said too long a sacrifice can
make a stone of the heart if your
troubles
so long and there have been times during
the last 30 years in Northern Ireland
when the search for peace may have
seemed futile but the sterile cycle of
violence and counter violence and
political failure that led to so much
devastation on our streets
it was despair that it could never end
but a well-known Belfast writer CS Lewis
once said that between no hope and very
little hope lies a vast ocean of
possibility in other words always be
positive look for the positive and not
the negative he was right in Northern
Ireland there always has been hope
ordinary people never lost faith that a
new road could be traveled on Good
Friday in 1998 the political parties of
all of the north of Ireland agreed to
walk a new road we chose the way of
peace of partnership of opportunity and
the people of Ireland north and south
opted to walk that new road with us
because for the first time in our
history this is rather surprising was
the first time in history the people of
Ireland as a whole north and our north
and south spoke as to hardly wish to
share the Peace of earth together when
they come out in the joint referendum
north and south on the one day and
overwhelmingly voted for the Good Friday
Agreement and that now makes it the duty
of all true Democrats in Ireland to
implement the will of the people and
those minorities that are seeking to
overthrow the agreement are working
against the will of the people there's
one of them who's a very leading
clerical politician and I said to me and
if you took the word no other English
language you'd be speechless and he says
no I wouldn't
but it's fight of our progress today
more than three and a half years later
we appear to only travel a short
distance but the Lord is a short
distance given our past number of
centuries of conflict it's quite a
distance and that's the nature of
conflict resolution there are no easy
answers or no quick fix solutions
it's a tough and difficult progress
process and of course as I've said it
will take the healing process to
complete it but we will not give it up
and we owe it to the people of our
country and to the wider world as I have
said to keep moving forward because when
you have the divisions of centuries as
we have and as most areas of conflict
tab you don't heal them in a week or a
fortnight it requires the healing
process the spelling of sweat and not of
blood
the working together in the common
interests and that's what we're now
doing and there's no doubt at all that
our people in Ireland have set out on an
irreversible course towards a peaceful
future the commitment exists to ensure
that we create a future where everyone
can enjoy equal and fundamental human
rights where every young Irish person
can find work and enjoy a good quality
of life where the pursuit of our common
interest is the most potent expression
of our shared patriotism the fundamental
implementation therefore of the Good
Friday Agreement is the vehicle for
delivering that new Ireland in which
Catholic Protestant in the centre will
live together in equality and respect
for diversity the time has now come for
the world as well to learn and as I've
already said and I keep repeating
because the time to make people think I
think that we and you you are the
generation that will be leading in the
new century and
millennium so the challenge is to make
sure that your influence is used to
ensure that the entire world learns that
humanity transcends difference the
difference is indeed that very essence
of humanity let them learn the
fundamental of your constitution a
pluribus unum from many we are one
it's message is very clear and it's a
powerful message of peace for the world
diversity is a good thing diversity is a
healthy thing diversity enriches the
world no longer can it be allowed to
drive us apart
the longer cannot be allowed to
perpetuate sterile and bloody conflict
instead the true potential of diversity
must be fostered as a valuable tool for
bringing people together for promoting
reconciliation and developing new and
dynamic relationships between peoples in
short as I've made clear no two human
beings are the same and Humanity is
richer for that difference where would
we be and what sort of a word would it
be if we were all the same he answered a
difference is to respect it and not to
fight about it to live for ideals to
live for your country rather than to die
or kill and as we begin the new century
the time has come for us all to respect
our common humanity the time has come
for us all to commit fully to achieving
the end of all conflict because the
victims of conflict and matter where
they are are human beings and to apply
the basic principles of conflict
resolution to all areas of conflict in
short the time for a peaceful world has
arrived in the words of President John F
Kennedy
spoken in 1963 but still as relevant
today as then and listen to what he said
we can help make the world safe for
diversity for in the final analysis our
most basic common link is that we all
inhabit this small planet we breathe we
all breathe the same air we all cherish
our children's future and we are all
mortal that is an icy cart that way of
peace and justice for all the world when
you think of those words in 1963 about
the small planet the planet today is
even much smaller therefore the
challenge that President Kennedy put to
us is much much clearer and stronger and
let us make it our dream our ideal at
the new century and a new millennium
will be a new century and a new
millennium
we're a pluribus unum will be the
principle of the whole world and the
whole planet thank you
dr. Hulme will accept some questions
there mics in several places
yes dr. Hume as a young person from West
Belfast Northern Ireland I just like to
take this opportunity to say thank you
to you I know that was like your
sterling work over the last thirty years
people like myself would never have had
the opportunity to have a university
education to have a vote and also for me
to be able to say that I can't the
daughter of Lord Taylor as one of my
good friends however I'm also very
concerned about the current political
climate at the moment they're continuing
protests in our doing at the Catholic
school the breakdown of the loyalist
ceasefires and there are some
revelations that unionist politicians
have been speaking to loyalist
paramilitaries while at the same time
trying to bring down the assembly in
refusing to set in parish in fear I'm
just wondering how you perceive the
situation developing over the next few
years well as I said earlier you know we
have come three-and-a-half years and
it's not as far as we'd want to have
come but we have made considerable
progress as I say the vast majority of
our streets there's peace in our streets
and the atmosphere is being transformed
but there have been some recent
difficulties and one of the difficulties
of course relates to the implementation
of the agreement and the point that has
to be made about that which I've already
made is that it is the will of the
people that because when the agreement
was reached my party proposed I proposed
that that the last word would be with
the people and not with the politicians
so that nobody once the agreement was
put into place could then oppose it and
claim they were acting in the name of
the people the people overwhelmingly
voted for their first rigidity
implemented therefore the one area of
Congress controversy at the minute to be
implemented is what's called a
decommissioning area and
words that Poli military organizations
like the IRA should with the
International Commission general of the
chastened nobody's asked them to
surrender but they should show the
International Commission that their guns
have been put beyond use they should do
that as soon as possible and that will
transform the atmosphere and I hope that
they will do so secondly David Trimble
and company should not be talking about
withdrawing from the institutions like
the executive as the as you have said
they're not doing because they're again
what they're doing is working to bring
down the agreement that the people have
overwhelmingly voted for and of course
there is also certain elements in
paramilitary organizations who are
trying to keep the troubles going and
north Belfast you mentioned and my
belief is that what's happening there is
there certain elements in paramilitary
organizations who don't want low an
order or peace in our streets because
they want to keep up their mafia work in
the drugs trade and it's not about
politics and therefore that the whole
community should unite totally and
absolutely against them in order to get
that stop because and I know nothing
strangely enough and I'm sure you'll all
agree with me I know nothing in the
whole 30 years in Northern Ireland that
got as much international publicity as
those children being stopped going to
school in north Belfast and when it
started I was in Strasbourg at the
European Parliament and it had never
happened before but my colleagues from
Germany and France and Spain and Italy
we're all walking up to me John what is
wrong what sort of people are that
they're stopping your kids from going to
school and of course I went on the radio
and television immediately to Belfast to
say I'm speaking to the Protestant
people the image that's going out to the
world is that the Protestant people are
stopping these children going to school
and I know that that is not correct
because the vast majority the Protestant
people are not involved in this there's
a certain minority involved therefore I
called on the Protestant church leaders
and politicians to come out and condemn
it and they've come out and made clear
their opposition to it and we have been
working to get meetings between the
residents and the skills to get the
matter resolved but as I say there's
those who are trying to stir it up but I
hope we will get a result what does it
say how when you're ending centuries of
conflict you don't get rid of the
distrusts at the heart of the division
in a week or fortnight it does require
the healing process and the framework
for our healing process our new
institutions and we must preserve those
mr. Hume my name is Jared curry and I'm
on the faculty at the Sloan School where
I teach negotiation I realized this
question may be outside of your
immediate expertise but given that the
title of your talk is the philosophy of
conflict resolution I wanted to ask you
to comment briefly on the current
situation between the United States and
the war on terrorism specifically
President Bush was quoted recently as
rejecting what may or may not have been
a serious offer by the Taliban for
negotiation and I'm curious as to what
you think about that stance and how your
three principles might apply to this
conflict well first of all I think that
the the terrible atrocities committed in
New York and Washington had great
sympathy right across the world with the
American people and there's absolutely
no doubt about that and I have no doubt
either that there's strong unity across
the Democratic world that all democratic
governments should get together with the
United States administration and to do
everything in their power to bring to
justice the individuals and
organizations that committed those
atrocities
but in so doing to ensure and to do
everything in their part to ensure that
innocent people don't suffer that's one
of the dangers of this type of situation
that if innocent people suffer it
creates more recruitment for the where
the terrorist organizations but the
other thing that I would like them to do
as well is to ask for the reasons why
those people did that to find out why
did they do it because quite often in
terrorist activity the terrorists who
engaged in it believe in what they're
doing even though they're wrong
everybody else thinks they're wrong for
example to get the violence stopped in
my own country I got into direct
dialogue with organizations that were
involved even though I totally condemned
what they were doing I asked them to
state the reasons for the violence and
they stated them and I said well two
reasons the British and Ireland
defending their own interests by force
therefore we're the right use force to
put the might and secondly they're
preventing the Aires people from
exercising the right to
self-determination so I said look reason
number one used to be through in the
past but it's not true in today's modern
world Britain there's no economic or
strategic interest in being in Ireland
today our problem is the legacy of that
past we divided people and secondly the
Aires people if you describe them as the
people who live on the island as a whole
will have the right to
self-determination yes but unfortunately
they're divided as to how to exercise it
therefore its agreement we require their
reply to me was you prove that and will
choke it will stop the violence so in my
dialogue with Terry Adams we got I was
asking the British and Irish governments
to make a declaration which said that
and they did see it the dining street
declaration in other words even though
most people would disagree with the
reasons then proved to these people that
the reasons didn't exist anymore now I
don't know and I have to admit that I
don't fully understand the situation
that
led to this these attacks but an attempt
should be made to find out exactly why
did they do it and then address those
reasons as well as because no matter
what reason they did it for their method
of doing it was appalling and all the
people who died were totally innocent
people and therefore they should be
brought to justice
and their organizations as well but as I
say it would also be useful to know why
did they do that and why he did an
organized group of people do that what
are their reasons and address the
reasons as well doctor whom I'm very
excited about the ID or saying about the
referendum how that kept me from
co-opted in the process by showing that
all the people were behind it now the
problem is that last week I went and
heard Paul Simon talk about the Marshall
Plan which was behind the as you know
some of the foundations of the EU and
the piece that we've had in the last 40
years in Europe and he said only 18
percent of Americans supported the
Marshall Plan when it was implemented
and he was particularly concerned that
right now politicians in America
couldn't go against the general popular
desire which is not exactly towards
conflict resolution at least not
peaceful conflict resolution so I don't
know what my question is I like your
idea and I'm wondering how can you
implement it I guess in the general case
I don't understand you
you explain what you're asking me about
yeah the question is do you think it
generalizes that you can get a popular
referendum to support a peaceful price
process I guess that's the short version
well if what I was talking about areas
of conflict I was talking about divided
communities in different parts of the
world that are conflicting with one
another
like the Middle East is a prime example
of it for example and again it's about
territory what I'm saying is first and
foremost and violence because it is no
role to play in solving the problem it
only deepens the divisions secondly get
into dialogue and talk and reach
agreement as to how you share pieces of
Earth and then get the people to approve
of that in referenda then nobody can
come out with a gun and say oh we're
sold out we have been sold out we can't
say that if the people have voted for it
and that's why I think that it's a very
powerful element and conflict resolution
situation and in a peace process hi my
name is Badal Zaveri I'm a student
graduate student here at MIT and also a
native of Pakistan which seems to be a
lot in the news these days my question
is that recently polls in the u.s.
showed that 92 percent of the u.s.
population is behind the u.s. behind
George Bush the pollak political
leadership and the attacks that have
happened in the aftermath and the
military action against the Taliban on
the other side 82 percent of the Muslim
population in many of the countries have
sort of caught off or sama bin Laden a
terrorist in some sense as you know a
leader given those kind of support
coming from the people the populations
how do you see political leadership who
thrive on such people mass is supporting
them how can they align themselves into
negotiation it almost seems as though
people are you know happy with the war
that's going on they're happy that
there's retaliation or they're happy
that a war is developing and you know
somebody will win so how do we move from
such winning the war and and
and winning the people over to a
conflict resolution which may not be
totally supported by people well how you
do it is what I've said first of all and
I know that this is what the people are
supporting working to bring to justice
the people who committed those terrible
atrocities vast majority of the people
of the world support bringing those
people to justice but what I'm talking
about
in terms of Oh conflict resolution where
you have areas of the world where two
sections of people are in conflict who
live in the same areas that their
agreement should go to the people now
what we're talking about here in the
American situation in relation to to
those atrocities the full facts haven't
yet emerged therefore you know people
can't make up their minds until the full
facts do emerge like what first of all
who exactly were the people who did this
and why did they do it and they
certainly have to be brought to justice
for doing it because there's no
justification of any description we're
doing what they did and they should be
brought to justice but if the reasons
gave birth to people like that and are
likely to continue to give birth to
people like that then the reason should
be addressed as well in order to
demonstrate to people on the ground in
those areas but those reasons don't
exist and if there is some bitterness in
those regions are rising out of the past
as we know I mean our quarrel started in
1689 you know and therefore there could
still be there while while this country
has modernized and gone on and on and on
many people would have forgotten
completely anything that happened even
twenty or thirty years ago you know so
what are the reasons there is all I'm
saying I don't know what they are I
would like to know if there were reasons
and what they are you know and or maybe
they were just traditional religious
reasons you know
from that those type of people who have
a very strange notion about religion I
don't know what the reasons were but I
would like to know what they are and
then when they are brought forward they
should be addressed yes dr. Hume
traditionally in Northern Ireland
political power has grown from people
who've been successful as politicians
have been successful because they've
held their ground because they've stood
firm because they haven't changed and
I'm wondering whether in your case
whether you see the peace process as
being a vindication of a direction that
you chose some time ago in which you and
on which you held firm or have you
changed in your positions and if you
have change what's is that what does
that experience being like well I
haven't changed myself I went into
politics to solve problems to solve a
particular problem and my first election
in 1969 in my election literature which
can be read I said I was seeking a
mandate to find a Social Democratic
Party and I wanted to get away from the
flag-waving politics and that the unity
of our country which we would support
could only come about with a consent of
a majority of the people in the north in
other words it could only come about by
agreement why we were saying that in
1969 at last 32 years later the whole of
nationalist Ireland are now saying the
same thing but it took a bit of time but
also our approach to the problem hasn't
changed throughout our existence as a
party because the problem hadn't changed
therefore neither that our approach to
solving it and our approach to solving
it was based on our analysis of the
problem number one we divided people not
a divided piece of earth therefore were
totally and absolutely opposed to
violence secondly we're divided on three
sets of relationships as I said earlier
and those should be the agenda at any
talks and the two governments should be
working together
to reach agreement with all the parties
and thirdly when agreement was reached
it should be approved by the people and
not the politicians that was our policy
it's all on the record down to 30 years
we stuck by it and stuck back as I said
and I kept using the same language all
the time they call it human speak now
you know because I kept saying the same
things it's the old teacher and me you
know when you write to persuade people
you don't persuade them in one sentence
or one speech you have to keep out it
now when a man and a pope uses the
language back to me I realize right I
can move on and change my language but
that as I'm saying we have studied stood
by not and the people are aware that we
have done that and as I say the the what
certain unionists haven't realized is
that the whole of what's called
nationalist Ireland now accepts that the
unity of the country can only come about
with a consent of a majority the people
of the north as well as the majority the
peoples of size divided people therefore
agreement to both sides and that's been
our consistent position throughout the
people know that and of course certain
other parties who felt that the way to
solve the Aires problem was through
violence I recognized clearly that that
was completely wrong and that the
strategy and tactics of that was also
completely wrong and of course you can't
be looking to defend the human rights of
your people if your method undermines
the most fundamental human right of all
right to life and therefore as I say I
have every confidence that the people in
our land know exactly not only what
we've done to represent them but that we
have stood firm on our policies and
convictions if we have four people here
and there will be our last questions
first person hello thank you for
speaking this evening early in your
speech you mentioned that you are very
successful and bring economic interests
into
Ireland or game the promises for that
following a peace process in particular
the International Fund for Ireland and
you mentioned briefly that you had both
the very strong educational background
of your people and you had the close
ties with America and looking to
generalize that success how do you think
other countries where there are economic
problems that are leading to the lack of
peace how can they learn from it and
form some more basins for a peace
process well of course if they address
the center of their conflict and they
reach agreement they then create the
circumstances where they working
together and some in many areas of
course when I was talking about this
earlier today in many areas of the world
where there's terrible poverty and lack
of you know there's also a major lack of
education and as I have said when we're
sending aid to third world countries we
should also be making sure that they get
an educational system because the aid
can be used in a week and then the next
week they're looking for more where's
the real wealth is its people and it's
people who create and people are far
more equipped to create when they're
educated an education and this is my own
experience tells me this is the major
factor in the economic development of
any country and therefore it should be a
major factor particularly in the third
world and in poorer countries getting
education in there to develop I mean in
my own part of the world I can see her
education transformed our society I was
among the I was the first generation
people of my age to get educated in
Northern Ireland who didn't come from a
rich family my father was unemployed
that was the eldest of seven children
yeah
right through the university because the
very first year of the new system the
eleven plus exams was called I got the
scholarship before that there was no
education available at high school level
or the university level to people whose
parents couldn't afford to pay for it
that transformed our society and if you
look at Ireland today for the first time
ever the Irish economy is
self-sufficient why because we now have
a total educational system throughout
the whole island in other words once
again coming back to my principal
respect for humanity human beings are
the only wealth we have in the world
make sure that they're most able to
create that by making sure that they're
as fully developed as possible with
their own skills and talents through an
educational system and indeed there's
nowhere and I am talking there about
normal education like going to primary
school and go to secondary school go to
university and yet I'm saying it in a
building where the modernization of
education is fantastic and what you're
doing and I'm talking about the
Institute here not only to develop the
skills and talents in the high tech
world but also to create right there the
the employment in this whole new field I
mean it's just proving how how societies
can be transformed and what a difference
it can can make and it's education is
the first step on the road dr. Hulme
it's a great opportunity to be to meet
somebody like you for somebody like me
who was born and have been living in an
area of conflict for 30 years being a
Middle East and myself a Jordanian from
a Palestinian origin
I really we have been all as Middle
Eastern I think looking at the the Irish
experience with great interest and
having listened to your principles do
you think that resolving conflict in a
situation like our
and could be somehow copying in a case
of where conflict is under a situation
of occupation rather than just the
vision of people well thank you
you see in Ireland one of the political
Jews was at a part of the island was
being occupied by Britain you know but
what I'm saying is the principles at the
heart of our agreement are the exact
same principles that ended conflict
between the peoples of Europe here the
two world wars and when you apply those
principles to the Middle East
the first message to get over to them is
that they have a quarrel yes but the
first thing to learn is that violence in
no shape or form will solve their
quarrel it'll only make it worse because
people on both sides will lose their
lives therefore the first thing we
should do is stop their violence and
that's common sense the second thing we
should then do is sit down and talk and
discuss how do they share the piece of
earth together you know where you're
talking about occupational but how they
actually share the piece of earth
together and they do it in a manner
where it's people that have rights and
not territory and that's what I'm
talking about in terms of our agreement
that the government the new government
of Northern Ireland all sections of our
people are in the government of that
piece of earth it's people that are
running the piece of earth not the piece
of earth running the people and the same
principle could apply to the Middle East
I think if they just sit and reach
agreement because once again let's not
forget that people were born in a
particular place he didn't choose to be
born there other people say you
shouldn't have been born there it should
have been me you know but as I say that
being the case
should agree how they share a piece of
Earth not the piece of earth governs
them you know because as I say before
what is a piece of Earth is there's no
people so they shouldn't be fighting
about territory they should be agreeing
as to how they live together in
territory and you know also of course I
have often said and it's been
misinterpreted deliberately with some of
my own political opponents we're living
in a post nationalist world today there
are those who think that the
nation-state is an eternal concept but
before the nation states there were
city-states etc etc and as the world got
smaller
you know the nation-states grow now as
the world is getting smaller still
we're coming countries are coming closer
together like in Europe today we don't
have independent European countries we
have interdependent European countries
because they're all working together in
their common interests and you take the
most fundamental industry of all the
industries provides your food all
decisions in agriculture for 15 of the
countries are taken at European level
not at national level so the world
evolves and the nation-state is not an
eternal concept we've moved beyond it
but what doesn't change is that it's
people who are living in the world and
it's people who have to live together
therefore it's people who should agree
and how they live together not deciding
that one piece of Earth has to get some
people out of it and other people into
it yes sir hi I'm concerned that this
country's current reaction to the
tragedies of September 11th will simply
be part of a cycle of violence that that
we've only just begun to see and I'm
concerned that we've in reacting to the
events of September 11th we're not
seeking justice and rather were seeking
vengeance with violence part of that
concern is due to the fact that we've we
haven't paid any attention to to seeking
the role of the United Nations in
seeking justice and I was wondering if
you could comment on any potential roles
that the United Nations could play and
how we can strengthen that role and get
the United States to subscribe to it
well I've already spelled out what I
think about that situation and as I say
that the people should be brought to
justice and that they should be done so
in a way that innocent people don't
suffer and they should also address the
reasons and another way of course you've
made a good point there that the reasons
could be brought forward fully and
clearly and objectively would be if the
United Nations were to go into that area
and find out what what was the reasoning
behind all of this and explain that and
make their proposals as to how to ensure
that that sort of thing is not repeated
last question
dr. Hume thank you very much for coming
to speak about issues of conflict
resolution to the academic community of
the Boston area I'm a graduate student
from the Fletcher School of Law and
Diplomacy just down the road
you mentioned actors who attempt to
undermine resolution efforts and you
mentioned that the people should come
out against such unrepresentative
factions but my question is how do your
principles of conflict resolution relate
to a complex conflict such as the one in
the Democratic Republic of Congo in
which those who have a vested interest
in fueling a conflict conflicts such as
a proxy war for natural resources are
far more powerful and empowered than
those who suffer from the conflict even
those who suffer on both sides of a
conflict that benefits others well in
areas of that nature of course where you
have what you're talking about forms of
dictatorship etc that's what the United
Nations are
existence for to deal with problems of
that nature and the United Nations
should positively move into areas live
it got and describe to the world first
of all describe to the world the
situation that exists in order to put
pressure on those who are abusing power
and create the the process which will
lead to adjust society in such areas but
you know in dealing with an issue like
that I would like to study the whole
problem and depth before Co and then
come up with proposals to deal with it I
was talking in general terms about areas
of conflict where the conflict is clear
between two communities you know but
other areas are more complicated stuff
the United Nations and of course as I've
often said about the United Nations they
shouldn't just be sending armies into
areas of conflict we should be sending
in a philosophy as well to solve the
problem because normally what happens in
divided societies when you send an army
onto the streets it may stop the
violence but what happens and each side
they keep getting more and more guns
waiting for the army to leave and
therefore they should be taking in the
philosophy and I have also been
proposing recently at European level at
the European Union given that it's the
best example in the history of the world
of conflict resolution while it has many
departments and normal departments of
Agriculture etc and economic departments
it should also have a department of
peace and reconciliation and there
should be a European Commissioner for
peace and reconciliation and they should
take the philosophy down into the areas
of conflict and talk to the different
sides involved and bring in the
philosophy not an army okay
thank you very much
you